how are you know Chris has this amazing
ability to look at a staffer and tell
you whether he there would be a top or a
bottom like in the gay world yes he's
very good at it Chris
oh you're a bottom oh yeah he's like a
bot like a like a whiny bottom [ __ ] boy
[Music]
boom I'm at two it's like you know I got
the hot you wanna want to stick it in
then once you stick it in it's like oh I
don't it doesn't feel right can I get
out oh I didn't clean back there
it's an annoyance versatile like he's
sort of like a Brooklyn getting fog by
being a girl or feel like getting the
job done what about Gary there's a box
Gary's a bottom surely I think we'd
surprise you surely citta I think
Shirley's hiding some impressive
equipment under all of it yeah I think I
think that I'm going on there and I do
see you know he's Israeli so there is a
commanding send all those swinging
exactly what about Richard and sound
well this is the problem which is how
they're both bottoms and that's why they
always want to do something with each
other but it never really posted about
JD i JD's a top JD has swagger really
yeah off the year JD's got something
going on Oh what you know a key you got
a big crush on him right well I yes I
believe I've heard he has a very big
penis and he said he [ __ ] hard I
believe he would be pretty relentless on
a whole Benjy he's a bottom I'm Ralph a
whiny [ __ ] didn't you say Jason was
like a very feminine bottom I think he'd
be he'd be a big friendly bottom like
you'd [ __ ] him and he might like you
know fall into his [ __ ] he might like
cry after sex not good he's in pain just
because it's like so loving